événement dans le monde des médias le
groupe tf1 est en train de racheter son
concurrent m6 je vais tout vous
expliquer à sur ce qui se passe sur ce
qui s'est passé sur les coulisses tout
ça je vais tout vous raconter il ya
thierry moreau qui va venir nous
rejoindre également parce que j'avais
envie de le voir et j'aime beaucoup
en gros logo bouygues propriétaire de
tf1 a acheté prendre pour cent des
titres du groupe m6 où elle est tenue
par le groupe allemand c'est un groupe
allemand martin et des chaussures cette
fusion des deux groupes coûte 641
millions d'euros à brides hier 640 balle
le but créer un gros groupe médiatique
pour mieux combattre les plateformes et
faire des économies serre qui verra des
synergies entre tf1 et m6 donc forcément
il va y avoir des licenciements
même s'il ya un assez bon alors on va
vous parler de tout ça regardez comme
ils en ont parlé sur tf1 c'était dans le
13h de tf1 regardez en unissant leurs
forces
les groupes tf1 et m6 veulent devenir un
champion français de la télé de la radio
et du digital sur vos téléviseurs
rien ne changera la une est l'assise
garderont leur place le nouveau groupe
deviendrait le quatrième plus gros
médias européens chiffre d'affaires 3 4
milliards d'euros afin de peser face aux
géants américains que sont explique ce
disney ou encore facebook
les discussions devraient durer 18 mois
mais il faudra obtenir le feu vert de
l'autorité de la concurrence sur deux
points la publicité car les deux groupes
dominent le marché et le nombre de
chaînes possédé par le nouvel ensemble
dix au total aujourd'hui alors qu'un
groupe ne peut détenir que cette chaîne
sur la tnt
bon c'est simple ils vont bien c'est bon
la chute prochaine oui juste le mec qui
l' ont il est en train de manger quand
il faisait le doigt vers le gars il est
contraint de démonter
[Applaudissements]
alors on a vu pourquoi téva ratchet m6
bat pour se ressourcer européen qui
passe et reprennent c'est qu'au niveau
mondial on va rester des nains très
clairement ouais parce que les deux
chiffres d'affaires c'est 3,4 milliards
ce que vous avez dit on et démarre lundi
warner s'est rapproché discovery ils
vont peser 53 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires
ohlala en 2023 dont contrat veut dire
qu'on va rester des nains ah ouais bon
c'est pas pour combattre netflix ac
c'est pour l'affichage si vous voulez
c'est pour résister aux plateformes
encore mais on ne gagne jamais combattre
ni netflix ni discovery ni aucune des
grandes plateformes pêche le pdci n'est
pas de choquer aujourd'hui
la raison sirigu entier dit qu'on est on
fait on fait 3 milliards et des
reniements 50 milliards ouidène un but
par but he cunnilingus du contre canal
parce que il me semble que d'un point de
vue économique en tout cas tf1 m6 ils
sont loin du groupe canal+ d'affaires
oui oui donc déjà au moins il sait pas
pareil parce que c'est de la télé avec
canal on est gratuite les acteurs
ouverte isme en évidence qui me met dans
l'escaut ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
peur que la télé gratuite soit finie que
ce soit que de la télé payante
maintenant une des plateformes qui qui
qui domine incessamment ya pas il n'y a
pas que ça parce qu'ils ont d'ailleurs
dans le projet de créer une plateforme s
vod qui veut dire d'ailleurs que c'est
toi du plomb dans l'air ce qu'on sait de
l'exactitude c'est le début des
négociations on savait que c'était une
connerie comme l'ont déjà la paix salto
déjà senti mal dans mes séries
alors est-ce que qui va être le gagnant
et le perdant dans cette histoire les
gagnants ne connaissez pas encore les
actionnaires surtout parce que 90% de
tout ce qui va être générée comme
économie et comme me cache ce qu'on
appelle le free cash flow de ces de
cette fusion va aller aux actionnaires
dont les actionnaires font une très
bonne affaire beaucoup moins les
annonceurs ceux qui font de la pub ils
vont être face à quelqu'un qui va fixer
les prix arthur est à dire sans doute
des producteurs c'est une très mauvaise
nouvelle parce qu'avant tu avais un bon
projet tu pouvais faire monter un peu la
sauce en 3 m6 c'est à dire exactement
avant d'aller chez tf1
moi c'est ce que je faisais tout dans 10
à tf1 à vous ne voulez pas tant pis même
si je trouve ça n'est jamais été pour m6
bien sûr la trappe c'est à dire m6 le
veut et ça paie tout droit
[Applaudissements]
ok donc les producteurs vont pas en
profiter oui c'est clair
et les téléspectateurs vont sans doute
avoir trois chaînes de moi même si c'est
pas sûr qu'ils vendent les chaînes on
accroche à mettre sur les plateformes en
tout cas ils auront moins de chaînes
sont arrivés on est derrière a priori
tf1 syrie fim et sister bon il va y
mettre bon peut-être les maths sur les
plateformes km sur leur plateforme vod
les bras mon tir il voit pas qui va
acheter cinq mois avant les premières
sommes une petite pépite qui peut être
intéressant aux côtés de ses comptes et
me vendre ou nous le monde c'est râpé
euh non mais ça c'est vrai qu'on mettra
fin au non voilà j'aime beaucoup paris
combien voilà personne je vois pas qui
va racheter ça alors c'est après il ya
il ya plein de questions qui se posent
il ya les téléspectateurs qu'ils y met
ce que un animateur de tf1 va pouvoir
aller sur m6 je crois pas non ils vont
garder les autres assurent ils ont
quitté intérêt à garder le public et
quand quelqu'un regarde m6 y regarde pas
tf1 l inverse donc ils ont intérêt à
garder ce nombre de tes specter global
qui est diffusée sur toutes ses chaînes
donc ils n'ont pas intérêt à faire trop
de deux passerelles en revanche
d'ailleurs pour les gens de tf1 des
passerelles vers rtl je pense c'est ça
très cartel ça fait très longtemps
non mais c'est vrai très longtemps que
tf1 veut une chaîne de radio là sur une
ancienne station de radio et là ils ont
enfin une station de régulières à part
la matinale est peut-être un petit truc
à remuer les grosses têtes ils bougeront
pas sachant que tout ça bougera en 2020
exactement dont alors sa chaîne de
changer c'est dissuader il faut tout le
monde dit il faut que ça passe auprès de
l'autorité de la concurrence car nico
connaît sa voie il faut attendre des
sujets noirs mais il faut appeler ça il
faut la paix pour le donner le bon c'est
une opération financière mais c'est une
opération de rentabilité il va y avoir
des synergies qui vont être faites
donc effectivement il va y avoir un plan
de licenciement puisque aujourd'hui vous
avez une double origine vous avez une
double diversification aujourd'hui m6 en
termes de rentabilité
c'est une rentabilité record est là 21,7
pour cent donc s'il applique à tf1
demain en un an c'est le groupe le plus
rentable c'est à dire aujourd'hui on est
à 3 4 sa large en termes il faut dire
que le grand patron exacte des deux
entités nouvelle pour nous parce que on
va avoir de meilleures relations avec
tf1 futur et voilà c'est nicolas
tavernost vous savez que j'adore qui est
le co patron de m6 actuellement qui a
toujours été qui j'ai toujours eu des
relations excellentes
c'est vrai que grâce à ça peut-être
qu'avec tf1 ça va aller lui aussi est
que nos relations
ce conte meilleur et c'est vrai que qui
d'autre que lui aurait peut être le
grand patron de cette entité
c'est pour moi un des meilleurs à la
télévision c'est le patron c'est une
reconnaissance à son travail où il a
réussi à rendre à seulement rentable
plus de 20% comme tu le disais c'est
c'est une bête celle de ben voila moi
j'ai une tendresse pour lui c'est cuit
il adore voilà il ment et c'est le sait
l'un des rares patrons qui non seulement
est un décideur un homme regarde les
programmes c'est ça un exemple scènes de
ménage c'est lui qui l'a donc voilà donc
à vernon va prendre le tout est ce que
c'est un petit camouflet pour les
patrons de tf1 alors le patron de tf1 en
fait
gilles pélisson il va être
l'interlocuteur de rigueur et nicolas de
tavernot à tf1 donc il va être
l'interlocuteur de l'actionnaire donc il
sera plus dans l'opérationnel alors je
me dis ok quand même interlocuteur ça
veut dire qu on va pas se mentir thierry
nous ici au des choses on n'est pas
voilà on va pas se mentir j'ai une
responsable du gie le passé voulu
raconter des histoires aux gens on n'a
rien contre lui mais j'ai une pétition
gauche chine
c'est le grand perdant de cette
opération bah oui un moment quant à deux
pas qu'on mette à deux patrons unies se
réunisse tu te dis que quel va être le
patron est ballotté lahccen c'est tout
tu sais tf1 m6 sont pas plus compte
tours ils ont dit c'est qui le meilleur
tracé de tavernot c'est comme si tu
avais federer et e0 et j'ai maintenant
devenir quelqu'un et pourtant ma nicolas
tavernost est opposé un démantèlement du
groupe
oui enfin il était favorable quand même
remplacement avec tf1 parce qu'il savait
avec fait arrêter deux entre les sexes
qui servent à rien dans les discussions
que saisi six importants mais si on se
relâche du point de vue du
téléspectateur
est ce que par exemple tf1 et m6 vont
continuer à se faire une course à
l'audience est ce qui rend d'ailleurs
tenté d'avoir des cabanons je mets donc
je met rien en face de toi donc ses
proches mais rien en face devrait pas
avoir un grand patron c'est nicolas de
tavernot il va harmoniser ses grilles si
un mec qui dit quand un film sur 6 tu
vas avoir peut-être un divertissement
sur tf1
quant à une grosse série sur tf1 tu vas
avoir peut-être un truc plus faibles sur
m6 va pas grave un peu plus de gaieté
valence à l'instant le lancement d'une
grosse série sur têt 'pilotes' chef
monsieur c c'est comme quand on est
patron d'un groupe avec plusieurs
chaînes voit la même chose
votre fille ou sur le service et pour
l'information comment ça se fasse parce
que du coup ce qu'il y aura là encore la
pluralité de l'information ça c'est
intéressant chez le roi de la formation
et la catégorie d'actions lci tf1 qui
serait déjà un peu rapproché sa liberté
elle est celle de m6 alors évidemment
sur le papier elle voit rester chacune
dans leurs entités mais évidemment il y
aura des synergies sur les services
transverses
évidemment c'est pas mon salon terme
toute façon ils ont prévu de faire entre
250 millions et 350 millions d'euros
d'économies pendant trois ans à partir
de 2023
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya des gens qui
vont perdre leur emploi parce qu'il y
aura forcément dans les services de
transfert des gens qui vont se retrouver
sur le carreau mais qui obtiendra donc
tous les services et peut-être pas fait
s'il ya là lorsqu'ils ont pris quelques
garanties à wil et la concurrence ça va
être long ça va être compliqué parce que
juridiquement c'est un gros dossier mais
ils vont aboutir de toute façon y aura
des petites restrictions ils vont dire
que rajoelina - ça mais est plutôt
qu'ils demandent qu'est-ce que yassir et
2 contres
j'ai pétition de tf1 je vous raconter
une petite histoire en fait moi j'avais
rien du tout je connaissais pas que les
lepénistes je vais rien contre lui il
avait là il a une tête sympathique et
très sympa et un jour il est allé dans
une conférence avec des étudiants et je
sais pas pourquoi il a fait une demi
heure à me défoncer il ne connaissait
pas on ne savait pas c'est que c'était
filmé la vidéo c'est ballot textes et
mes charges avec son numéro un abubakar
doigt là où ça fait mal mais je vous dis
j'ai rien contre lui chez lui j'ai pas
compris il a voulu faire le malin
voilà qui fait le malin voilà maintenant
bombe h aujourd'hui on n'a rien contre
lui on espère qu'il va se retourner qui
pourra travailler que nicolas de
tavernot et ce avec nico est tellement
c'est un monstre
sa trémie c'est un monstre c'est le
numéro un si effectivement comme le dit
nicolas il impute les méthodes c'est toi
qui naissent à qui il applique les
méthodes de mentalité et f1 ça va
évidemment sont bien sûr nommé dressons
les groupes en bourse donc il va
appliquer il est l'arrière sueur des
deux qui a gagné la bataille il est là
pour auront de ce groupe ultra rentable
est-ce que vous rendez compte que j'ai
fait un petit exercice hier sur la
journée d'hier est ce que vous savez ce
que représente ce nouveau groupe en part
de marché sur les responsables sur les
femmes responsables des achats font 5,5
pour cent ce qui est énorme
il est coiffé comme mémé mari
nos jours oui les normes des aveux pour
taire parce qu'ils sont plus tout le
temps leader en audience comme avant et
surtout ils sont plus leaders en
comptabilité ils sont beaucoup moins
rentable m6 donc c'est très bien m6 veut
imposer un nouveau modèle de rentabilité
à tf1 thierry moreau vous disiez tout à
l'heure qu'ils vont faire comme delphine
ernotte c'est à dire en gros ils vont
pas faire une concurrence entre tf1 et
m6 mais exemple capitaine marley passé
de france 3 à france 2 oui ils vont pas
déshabiller de tf1 pour aller à m6 non
non non non de téléspectateurs entre
entre les psys c'était affaires sont
très différents alors que sur france 2
france 3 bons globalement tu peux tu
peux faire un transfert sans trop trop
secouer les choses là ils vont garder
les ans ils ont intérêt à garder les
identités pour avoir le plus de
téléspectateurs possible très clairement
et alors juste thiery on dit ça va pas
être un bon fin 2022
oui il risque d'avoir des complications
ça va être naturellement siens n'ont
affaire il ya quatre cabinets d'avocats
de conseillers juridiques fait un cap ça
va être un sage juridique ça va c'est le
voilà on le sait mais voilà à priori si
tf1 et m6 se sont mis d'accord c'est que
ça devrait passer
oui et sans doute avec la bienveillance
le gouvernement regarde le dossier ils
sont pas intervenir at il dit on dise
clairement arrêtée on va on va dire la
vérité on va pas comme quoi l'elysée
voulait absolument tout soit bien et non
pas les autres candidates rigolez ou
quoi sur ce genre d'opération vous êtes
obligés d'écrire qu'elle soit validée en
a mais je ne vous la faites pas vous
imaginer l'ont jamais cédé au groupe qui
peut être totalement déstabilisé
remercier imaginer le drame
mais oui si ça ne se fait pas mais ça se
fera non non non non mais imaginez le
drame
si on sait pas en 2022 ce qui peut se
passer en mai de 8 22 imaginons que le
président actuel ne soit plus président
les autorités de concurrence l'autorité
de la concurrence et le csa sont des
autres entités indépendantes
et les coups de fil voici les
chroniqueurs vous êtes un des pôles erp
aussi l'un des parents alors il atterrit
par l'autorité de la concurrence vous
verrez que elle elle continuera son
travail même si vous pensez pas claire
malapert dit comme vous qu'il est garant
de la vérité ah non mais tout peut être
remis en jeu politiquement bien sûr ça
peut ça peut changer on sera aucun cas
12 mois il restera six mois et là vous
avez quand même des passages vous à des
risques des délits d'initiés vous avez
des groupes cotés en bourse
vous avez des enjeux incroyable père
jury a enfin fait confiance à nicolas de
tavernot en dur et oui extrêmement fort
là dedans je vous lis en ce qu'il à
touba qui voit là je dis pas ça parce
que c'est vrai qu'il le sait qu'il est
beaucoup moins bon je m'en suis jamais
caché ici est vraiment c'est un vraiment
cessé c'est quelqu'un que j'aime
énormément qui nous a toujours arrangé
des coûts et qui a toujours été très
sympathique avec nous et c'est vrai que
voilà donc je pense que s'il y va c'est
bien sûr tout l'exemple des garanties
lui n'aurait pas pris le risque
et d'ailleurs je pense qu'ils ont nommés
nicolas terrain nous ça a énormément
rassuré également la bourse
quand il nous dit nicolas terra nostra
le patron du groupe s'est passé
crème combien ça pèse tf1 tf1 c'est 2
milliards oui c'est tout le milliard oui
mais provoqué le plus grand diffuseur
ses plus grands groupes audiovisuels
européens europe
oui mais parce qu'on est des nano
aujourd'hui on réduit la première
production audiovisuelle de france et du
monde pèse plus que tf1 tout à fait
c'est vrai aujourd'hui voilà c'est c'est
plus gros que tf1 c'est pour ça qu'on
n'ira jamais combattre les netflix on va
juste gens résistants avec nous trois
cadres 3,4 milliards ces surfaces à 22
milliards walt disney milliards et c'est
incomparable c'est pas le même acteur
aussi vous vous égarez pour une rançon
j'aimerais qu'on soit en effet isabelle
restera quand même sur rtl
ces bâtiments olivier marchal on est
tous on est plus près des pâtes que de
la nurserie un donc bientôt c'est dingue
c'est beau de terminer sur une passe
comme ça